YouTube is the new CNN YouTube is the
new NBC and for you to get a show on CNN
you're gonna need some bucks man but
what YouTube is what free that's right
welcome to the marketing podcast the
number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm shawn kennel
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content notice and
the latest money-making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your YouTube channel or you
want to maximize video across all of
social media this podcast is for you and
I am fired up for this episode
specifically because it comes from one
of the sessions at our previous grow
with video live conferences this is an
annual conference that we host for
online entrepreneurs and business owners
who want to start to understand
marketing who want to understand video
marketing and I know those terms kind of
get thrown around a lot but here's what
it means if you're ready to grow this
video then this is the conference for
you I'll tell you more about it after
this episode but if you're interested
you can go to growth video live.com to
claim your tickets this actual part of
groweth video live I felt needed to come
to you you need to hear this go ahead
and lean into this episode as Sean
shares these things with you right now
so here's one of the big reasons most
people fail with online video they
select the number one reason random acts
of content now look I'm all for random
acts of kindness of course right we
should be random and just see somebody
do something nice but if you're random
with your content with your messaging
you're never going to get momentum
on-line so what's the remedy to that
what's the remedy well I really believe
a way to kind of put handles and one of
our goals for you is to leave this event
with a game plan leave this event with a
game plan to dominate in 2020 and so we
really believe that one of the best ways
to do that
to create a signature show look at your
neighbor and stay start your show tell
them that look at the person on the
other say sided say you really need to
start your show say like that yeah so
here's why here's why the reason what is
the signature show like what's a
signature show well this is something
that comes out a consistent time right
consistent time a consistent place in a
consistent format that has a consistent
value proposition your show is not like
this is the personal finance show this
week we're gonna teach you about
budgeting and then next week your like
this week we're gonna be reviewing wine
you know and they're like oh that's
that's not consistent so so so it's
consistent time a consistent place
consistent format consistent value
proposition and then consistent branding
and that just simply means maybe you
create a little tagline intro you create
something that lets you know that it's
all consistent why does this help
because now we're avoiding random acts
of content and we're building momentum
with a signature show you know many of
today's top entrepreneurs that are
crushing it with online video have
started a show this is marie forleo as
something like over a half a million
subs 46 million views on her channels
she probably done over a hundred million
dollars in course sales and the way
she's built her business was by starting
a show called marietv
she started seven years ago and if you
ever watched an episode it's super
intimidating I mean it's like it's
crispy it's beautiful she's got a set
she's got a team and you go I can never
do that but if you go to a YouTube
channel and you go all the way back to
her oldest video you will find Marie
sitting on a couch in a tank top with a
laptop just answering questions she's
like yo welcome to the first episode of
Q&A Tuesday with Marie and she just
started a show right and now it's an
award-winning show not that lives on NBC
or ABC or CBS know it's it lives on
YouTube and I would dare say that what's
amazing is that YouTube is the new
CNN YouTube is the new NBC and for you
to get a show on CNN you're gonna need
some bucks man but what YouTube is what
free that's right and so so she started
a show and and the cool thing is again
yeah I mentioned this you don't have to
have a six-figure budget or a big
production team to do this there's her
first episode hey guys I'm on my couch
you know let's start the show and so you
got to just start simple
this is Brendon Burchard a powerful
influencer in kind of personal
development and like productivity and
his show is called the Brendan show he
posts one video a week on YouTube and
here's the cool thing even someone like
him it's got a big team make it like
making over eight figures a year doing
all kinds of stuff Brendan's not even
consistent all the time man I'm
sometimes I'm like dude where's your
videos bro he's like gone for two months
three months and so you're judging
yourself for not being consistent like
over the last say eight years he's been
consistent on a macro of just putting
out at least one show a week this is
Phil DeFranco and he actually does news
content on YouTube and so it's amazing
you could be in all different types of
niches or niches and you go all the way
back to his first episodes and there's
like a black and white web cam you know
there's old young Phil some weird
graphical intro thing with like the
weird reverse whatever and so it just
started ugly weird brutal how he all
starts but yet today he's one of the
most watched most subscribed news
youtubers and dare I say he gets more
traffic than giant news organizations as
a one-man show he just started being
consistent you can read this on the
headline it says the philip defranco
show monday tuesday wednesday and then
he's got a community show on friday and
he's just he started his show and stuck
with it started ugly but kept his show
going not only that today he's got
immense beard care line merchandise he
just started rogue rocket which is a
whole nother news organization but that
came later after starting a show look at
your neighbor tell him start
show telling that ja hey what are the
benefits of a signature show well the
benefits or clarity I mean there's also
like personal clarity like I don't know
about you but sometimes you wake up and
you might be like okay so I'm supposed
to make a video but I don't even know
what it's gonna be about like I have no
clue when you learn starting a show
you've already predefined what
everything's gonna be like maybe you
just need a topic but because you you
you have clarity of like literally what
you're doing and not just personal
clarity but it also let people
externally know what you're doing you're
like yeah I run a weekly show it's
actually a video podcast we upload on
YouTube and there's a podcast episode
over here and it brings clarity
simplicity it kind of clarifies just
what you're doing in terms of content
again you might be over here thinking
okay I'm supposed to do 60 second video
on Instagram and I'm supposed to be
doing stuff on LinkedIn and you can get
really stressed out really quick but the
cool thing about starting to show is you
just go okay this is it simple one show
a week what I want you to do every one
of us whatever we do when you leave go
with video I want you to this is your
game plan one a week just one a week one
show a week by the way your show could
be five minutes it could be twenty
minutes but one a week and because the
simplicity and you're like this is what
I'm doing this is the pillar I'm
planting consistency because now you
have a show you be consistent to your
audience by the way maybe you can't do
one a week there's a Cassandra here
front is doing like a LinkedIn live show
I was just watching the first episode
and and she said it she's gonna do it I
think once a month great or twice a
month but but just you can be consistent
with it branding this this could be
simple your words or maybe you spend a
few bucks and you can go to a site like
Fiverr calm or something like up work or
and get one of those branded intros
Heather will tell you I'm not even sure
how she made her intro but she only made
it like once for the home schoolhouse so
now she can sit in front of her phone
deliver content but then just play that
bumper and use a week after week so the
branding the look of it the name of it
can just be repeated you're not trying
to reinvent the wheel reinvent the
graphics you got him done once you could
keep working on them in your
number five Authority it's a it's
amazing because when you start a show
now you're like a show creator they
really are and you do it for a year you
do it for two years and you're like oh
yeah you know I'm the host of the highly
popular show the Sean show what do you
do I don't know I just talk and but I've
been owner for two years we have 104
episodes that's that's momentum right
that can really bring you into the
momentum number six when you do a show
momentum builds over time you're gonna
be hearing from sassy lashes in just a
bit and and their company and and
they've been doing it for just a short
time having a show but it's building
momentum and what's crazy is it's not
only good now but it's about to get good
er because momentum builds and builds
and builds and then finally
sustainability because all of us are
asking
you're like Sean I still got stuff to do
in my business man I still got the daily
operations I got other things to do in
my life but sustainability because once
you create systems around this now you
can kind of automate this I was talking
to Keith I just before the session he
said how are you guys are you guys still
happy or how do you guys do all the
things that you're doing and we said
well we're doing team stuff but we're
also trying to have smart systems create
buckets like a tip a week can I have a
glass of water I'm about to die
excuse me a tip of week you know and in
a tool a week so it's just buckets and
we're like put stuff in the buckets I
don't say this to discourage you but we
are so far ahead and think media right
now literally we have six months of
content ahead right now it only took us
10 years to get there thank you so much
but but I mean sustainability but it's
because we started building momentum
we're like wow and we just keep putting
we have clarity of what we're doing so
we keep filling those buckets here's
this PewDiePie's the largest independent
youtuber just crossed the hundred
million subscribers and he happens to be
doing minecraft all the time right now
but for a while there he was doing shows
he actually had multiple shows he was
uploading daily so he had meme review it
was a show pew news that was a show you
laughed you lose a show last week I
asked you that was a community show so
when you look at some of today's top
influencers and entrepreneurs that are
crushing it they have all started a
show this is [ __ ] [ __ ] actually lives
in Las Vegas pretty famous for knowing
for creating these crazy videos that are
just amazing of like with all kinds of
b-roll and stuff but recently they
launched a video podcast I actually need
you to tell your neighbor you need to
start a video podcast yeah it's called
the off the pill podcast right and so
he's they recently started that and now
they're able to be super consistent they
sit down they've got all the you know
the microphone setup you know where's
this is like in a closet right it's like
some corner some weird but they got the
stuff they got the gear they got it
setup they figured out what it is but
now it's rinse and repeat man it's just
a show that they do repeatedly this is
Palin from Palin's kitchen an interview
we did on video influencers and she has
a Cooking Channel one video a week
it's her weekly cooking show and from
starting on YouTube it's crazy because
she went to YouTube first uh it led to
traditional media she started getting on
local news
she got a book deal she got all kinds of
stuff just started super simple started
a simple show kept doing it for years
now she has seven hundred and thirty
five thousand subscribers and massive
momentum one of the kind of famous
social media entrepreneurs right now is
Gary Vaynerchuk and he's kind of known
for his personal brand but he also runs
an agency of about a thousand people on
his team and when you look at him you
should study the Great's and when you
look at him you see that his content
lives in buckets of shows the askgaryvee
show dailyvee is a show that he has
someone follow him around film him and
edit into blogs trash talk he started
just a hobby show where he goes to
garage sales buy stuff and flips it on
ebay that's a show original films
they're buckets you got to have your
organization now he's also got about
twenty twenty-five people just working
on his personal brand just editing
videos just at any microt content this
is why you never want to compare your
begin
to somebody else's middle because you
start doing the comparison thing and you
just go man I can never do that of
course either could he you've got 25
people helping him you know but but he's
putting his content out in buckets and
shows and listen to this and one of his
episodes he said if I was Gary Vee
full-time because he's actually a
business man full-time he does it very
part-time and his team helps him
leverage it but if I was Gary Vee
full-time like some of us want to just
build our personal brand or be
influencers I would have an Internet
show distributed on all platforms from
7:00 and 10:00 a.m. answering questions
so say look the strategy I would have if
I really wanted this thing to blow up is
I would start a show and here's the cool
thing - you actually don't have to be
the star of your show some of you your
business owner you're kind of thinking
about like can I do this should I do
this you don't actually necessarily have
to be the star of your show you could
still start one so this is Kingston like
technology they do memory and chips and
like flash drives and data drives and
things super exciting I mean you look at
the website there you just think wow
that's ripe for just an energetic
powerful show isn't it I mean my gosh
well here's what they did was they
started a DIY tips to improve your tech
show this is a model that should be
studied shout out to one of our sponsors
vid IQ Jeremy vest is here and he
actually helped consult on this was like
his brainchild helping them with this
strategy so connect with them at the vid
IQ booth not only his vid IQ an
incredible tool
but he's an amazing just digital
strategist he can help coach on your
YouTube channel you made even get him to
pull his laptop out and do a channel
review for you he's cool like that but
but he helped them with his strategy
because Kingston was like well how do we
start a show what do we do so what they
actually did was they brought in
somebody else as their talent trisha
hershberger actually has her own channel
but she contributes to their channel so
could you partner with somebody get
somebody that actually is just more
charismatic or that's more wants to be
on video or whatever
you don't have to be the star of your
show and you could still start a show
and the other thing to note from them is
that they're creating valuable the key
here is create valuable content for your
target audience and don't just market
your products so what's crazy on their
channel is they talk about how to shoot
stuff on cameras they'll talk about how
to get your computer running faster
guess what they talk about other brands
and competitor brands it's new school
marketing friends it's not just about
like direct hardcore sales it's about
just adding value educating becoming the
go-to expert and so they have all this
and then woven into the videos they're
uploading his videos about like their SD
cards and about like thumb drives and
how to use them
speaking of it IQ they've got an
incredible YouTube channel again they're
a software-as-a-service a SAS product to
help you grow your YouTube channel and
make data-driven decisions and so this
is Rob he's one of the people on their
channel that is the talent he's the star
of the show they've uploaded 24 videos
in the last month grew by 15,000
subscribers it's just been amazing about
what they've been doing and again vid IQ
and who here uses vid IQ wave at me wave
at me man amazing like half of it half
the room if you haven't heard about vid
IQ you could go to vid IQ comport slash
think you can grab the free a for sure
install the free plugin and it gives you
all this data about your YouTube channel
but you can also do a 30-day free trial
of their boost plan which is what we use
some incredible powerful things on our
pre sessions which will send you links
to those we did some pre conference
sessions who was on those wave of me we
did some zoom calls and stuff yeah and
so we did a training on vid IQ you can
check that out as well
this is Roger Wakefield the experts
plumber and we've known Roger for a
little while now I didn't realize that
he was actually sitting in the audience
at one of my sessions at a conference a
while back and he was catching a lot of
vision and getting inspired to launch a
show to start creating content and
what's been crazy is his channels just
been exploding in such a short time so
the first thing that happened was he
started to kind of realize maybe like
some of you that like okay
to be doing this but I'm not really sure
how to start and he's doing it kind of
half-hearted he was doing it not all in
and so at the end of 2018 he had 350
subscribers on his channel he also was
just uploading just videos titled like
honest plumbing company like self
describing you know like we're an honest
plumbing company that it's like hey you
know here's who we are but that's not
the stuff you may need some of those
things on your website and other places
but that's not the kind of content
that's gonna like help you build your
brand you need to think about the
audience first add valuable content
solve problem so he was telling me this
is when he got serious though was right
going into 2019 and he decided to go
all-in
he had an aha moment at a conference
like this and then he committed so his
son took on the video editing and
creation of their of their content and
they changed their entire marketing
strategy and it was a huge risk they
investment invested money they kind of
built this studio they started you know
doing some of that upfront cost and
heavy lifting stuff and and then he
started publishing videos now this is a
good one not just honest plumbing
company but how to fix a running toilet
guaranteed DIY plumbing repair sixty
five thousand views and they've only
been creating content for just a little
bit of time what's really cool is they
fired their marketing company they were
paying their marketing company around
twenty three hundred a month probably
invest about forty thousand dollars not
getting much results and since they
stopped spending money on their
marketing company and invested in
valuable content in things like editing
videos you know paying his son to edit
and investing in content not only has
their company revenue not gone down but
only increased they are now creating
extra influence and extra income streams
because of everything that they're doing
you got listed in Yahoo style Rodger
Wakefield on creating their life of its
dreams and inspiring generations some
super powerful things and their strategy
on the expert plumbers posting actually
three videos a week right now they're
growing by twenty five hundred subs a
month they're not at ten thousand yet
but they're growing by two thousand five
hundred a month 118 thousand views a
month
and and so his investment has all been
reallocated towards content and that's
the thing when it comes to momentum and
literally they are just getting started
give this guy I mean give him a month
but give him a year and it's it's game
over
um here's a couple of our inner circle
members that have started their show
this dr. kay you heard about him guess
what he's got that dr. kay show I
mentioned Cassandra right there's her
new LinkedIn live show coffee and
careers with Cassandra she helps people
focused on growing their career growth
skill skills helping others build their
careers you know get better jobs find
their she's a career consultant and
speaker so she started a show are you
getting the point tell your neighbor
start your show it's this Matthew
Matthews here at the conference where
you at Matthew right there Matthew's
passion is to help musicians start and
continue to create music so he does a
bunch of cool things on like beat makers
like the MPC and all kinds of stuff
right now because he's got his show
Matthew creating music helping people
with tutorials he's grown by three
hundred and sixty six subs a month
50,000 views a month almost a million
views on his channel I mean crazy stuff
happening but you gotta start your show
and this is the video podcast
cross-platform strategy right here so
this is Jay Baer I met Jay Baer Jay Baer
helps companies get customers for free
usually helps like a big big like
Enterprise Doubletree type of companies
especially through word-of-mouth
marketing he wrote a book called talk
triggers and you know Doubletree gives
away like free cookies and they get like
more free publicity from people being
like what a cookie and like tweeting it
be like oh my gosh you know we get
excited about cookies don't we you know
especially you eat part of it and then
the sugar kicks in and you're like oh I
love Doubletree whatever anyways word of
mouth marketing and so I was talking to
Jay about like his strategy but here's
what
he started a signature show right and so
he started the talk triggers show that's
the title of his book and he wanted his
book to be able to continue to be going
continue to be marketing and so he what
he does is he uploads like his show on
YouTube now but you might look at this
especially some of us that calculate ROI
and and I look at this and we're like
okay he's putting all this energy
shooting in his little home office there
in front of the avid and oarsmen thing
and talks to script he actually reads
off a teleprompter so he's got like his
thing dialed in he also set parameters
for a show it's always seven minutes or
less and what he does is he discovers
one company that's doing word of marque
mouthing word of Mart mouths word of
mouth marketing of her per a week on his
show so that any business that wants to
learn oh that's a good idea or that's
how he get customers talking about it
that's why they would subscribe but then
of course he uploads it on YouTube
81 views is that really worth it it's
really worth it to you know is for the
energy and the time to put it there but
what you don't realize is that his show
is platform agnostic because that same
show tweaked a little bit for LinkedIn
gets posted over on LinkedIn as well
seven minutes and over on LinkedIn oh we
got 876 views but not only that he's got
a system so then he can cut out a little
snippet of it and there's one of those
little micro pieces of content oh wow
that one blew up that got 1396 views and
so it's not only that that show also
lives on his website so anybody that
actually comes to his website he wants
to close business get clients well then
they can watch that show embedded from
YouTube on his website but it's also his
podcast look at your neighbor and say
start a video podcast
so he's creating just the one thing
right but he's being super smart with a
clock cross-platform strategy to
distribute it across platforms so let's
just talk about as we close here how to
systematize and scale your show so one
of the things we did on video
influencers that helped us launch the
number one best-selling YouTube strategy
book in the world called YouTube secrets
leading up to that was we started a
weekly interview show when we launched
video influencers I had a full time job
Benji was very busy doing some other
things so we actually had to say if we
only had a minimal amount of time we
were also living in two different states
if we had a minimal amount of time how
could we do this well let's start a show
in our case we would travel to events
and do a lot of interviews at events of
people so then that way we could put one
interview out a week and but a lot of
times we'd shoot maybe four to ten even
15 or 16 weeks of shows all in a couple
day conference pretty powerful and so
here's here's kind of how we do our show
we do always do an intro as we describe
that be the hook right then we have our
logo sting that's the bumper we describe
that that's at ten-second kind of
branding thing that we add in there now
we have a place for an ad spot cool
thing about that ad spot is as you grow
influence you could get a brand to
potentially sponsor you and start paying
you some money or maybe give you some
free product you're probably not gonna
start with that but the other thing with
that ad spot is if you watch our content
most of the time we just use that spot
to promote our own book and now it's a
play a thing that we could show other
people and say yet Skillshare you could
be here as well so it's the show Phil
DeFranco is another person to study for
that brilliant in terms of advertising
opportunities and how he incorporates
that then it's the content there we have
the lightning round just a feature of
what our show has you could have like
the quick questions or you could have
hey every episode you know I like to ask
you if you have an interview show like
whatever you do you know you structure
your show and then we have the question
of the day and if you've ever waved at
me if you've ever seen a video
influencers interview wave at me so a
lot of us have and so you've seen this
man this thing is rinse and repeat man
we just go and it's really nice because
we go to the conference we're not trying
to like be creative and make something
up new we just go these are the building
blocks we hit all of those and then it
allows us to create a sustainable show
video influencers is a side project for
Benji and I we each have full-time
businesses that could take more than
enough time for each of our lives but
we're able to sustain it because of
setting up simplicity and systems and
then there's the outro and on the outro
then we say hey thanks for checking out
this video and here's a couple tips
specifically about YouTube if you notice
how we're doing end cards YouTube now
allows you to kind of keep the viewer
cycle going to where we'll say hey
thanks so much for checking out this
video if you actually want to learn more
about whatever the topic we just talked
about click or tap the screen over here
for to watch this playlist on that thing
or watch another video click or tap the
screen right there the cool thing about
this second video is that YouTube allows
you this is during the last 20 seconds
of your YouTube video it allows you to
say pick a video that's best for the
viewer that's YouTube actually looking
at your library and picking a video that
that viewers most likely to click on if
they've watched the video before it
won't recommend that it'll recommend
something different so that one's always
different and this one's always
purposeful so we always will say hey if
you want to learn more about how to make
money with YouTube check out the
playlist just click or tap the screen
right here or if you want to watch
another video from video influencers
click or tap the screen right there
thanks again and subscribe if you're not
subscribed and that's our outro right
and so that is kind of a show framework
but you might have even been like ok I
don't even know if I'm ready for that
that sounded like a lot so you could
start even simpler than that when we
started video influencers here's me I
was living in Irvine at the time with
Sonya just walking in my neighborhood
with like a selfie stick in my phone
like and shooting the intro then we had
a buck of super super simple bumper that
was just like the logo and like this
video influencers cool and like a little
sound effect and then this is just a
Google hangout recorded video and I
don't know how I was able to make the
video quality this bad I this literally
I was like I am a Minecraft character I
don't know like James Wedmore looked
great but I was but we just started like
we just started simple and so I had a
little intro little bumper and then I
had the recorded interview and we
released it but you know what you could
start even simpler than that are like
first ever interview was like Benji and
Tim here split-screen nothing no music
no nothing like just like hey let's talk
about some stuff and so we had a Q&A
during VIP that was about like doing a
video podcast and like just recording a
zoom call just start your show like just
start recording something no matter what
it doesn't have anything fancy you can
start just like Murray did on her couch
and then you can scale as you go hey
look at your neighbor and say start your
show bro tell them that look at your
other neighbor and say start your show
okay so here's a quick summary for your
signature show study other shows some
brainstorm ideas what are people doing
in your industry but it doesn't matter
look in another industry like you could
take like I mean Phil DeFranco the way
he structures his videos have influenced
me a ton I don't do what he does but
study other shows and be like oh by the
way we got the lightning round from
entrepreneur on fire I was like he
doesn't lightning around and they didn't
invent that either like lightning rounds
have been around it's just the
rapid-fire question time but well I was
like oh okay we'll do a lightning round
and and so we just started to like
structure our show study other shows
brainstorm ideas start simple I implore
you even if you're like pumped up you're
like this is a vent and so amazing so
energized you know I'm gonna get them to
say a nice camera I'm gonna get you know
all the cool stuff here's the thing
complexity is the enemy of execution
yeah
complexity is the enemy of execution so
even if you're gonna scale we encourage
you to do so it's better to start simple
anyways because you want to just get
that first episode out setbacks are
gonna come your way right I mean just
life stuff you're like what happens if
setbacks come well if you make this
complex like hard to sustain thing then
it's gonna be hard to sustain but if you
kind of grow into it start simple and
then scale over time get help with
branding because if you're not great at
branding and you do maybe not good at
design or anything like that you only
have to do it once like even to the tune
if you were to spend a few hundred
dollars to just get a logo maybe figure
out some music figure out the bumpers
figure out some stuff like the talk
trigger show for Jay he has all of that
branding done and now he can run that
show for three years off of one little
branding package still start simple but
when you're ready to invest help someone
brand your show and then it'll just look
beautiful and you're good to go and then
create a pilot before you say okay Sean
said start a show I got to be committed
to this thing that I guess for the next
10 years of my life no you don't like
you you actually just need one episode
first right and think about what what
like TV shows do what they do is they
create a pilot
first to kind of get feedback on it you
might even like like just try a so idea
and then maybe it changes so you don't
have to commit for the long haul but
create a pilot get feedback on it but
the key is this start your show thank
you
well I hope you got so much value out of
that session from girl with video live I
know I did just real istening to it
again it just gets me excited about
creating content it really is just
pressing record pushing past the fears
and just getting started and again this
episode is brought to you by our annual
conference and grow with video live you
can get your tickets for as low as
ninety seven dollars right now at grow
with video live.com and this annual
conference it is a virtual experience
this year it's coming right to your
living room and when we say virtual
experience this isn't just you passively
watching a YouTube video or watching a
webinar this is you being engaged and
involved during this virtual conference
we've got community we've got ways for
you to win prizes there is so much
happening at this virtual conference you
don't want to miss it groweth video live
has been a sold-out conference every
single year and we're bringing the fire
and the energy all to your living room
and what I think we've been graced with
here at pink media or three different
areas when it comes to an online
conference you know Shawn and I have
attended so many conferences and we've
seen the good and we've seen the bad and
so we wanted to create a different
experience and one of those things that
we really love to hit on is the strategy
I've been to conferences before where I
leave with a journal full of who Roz and
yeah go Me's but I didn't actually leave
with the strategy that I needed to
implement in my business that's one
thing that we do here at grow with video
live we make sure that you leave with a
game plan you're going to get an action
book that you can take with you that you
can be filling out as we go through the
conference strategy is key and it's not
just strategy on YouTube its strategy on
all of the social platforms where is
video it's everywhere and we have
experts like chalene johnson sharing her
expert tips on Instagram we've got
katherine manning andrew
Oh Blake from YouTube sharing about how
they've grown on on the platform we have
so many people coming to talk to you
about LinkedIn and tik-tok and Facebook
I mean each one of these platforms
matter but what's the strategy to
actually growing on them that's one
thing you're gonna learn I grow up video
live the second is the psychology you
know for me this is actually the piece
that held me back for so long I waited
three years before I pressed record
because I was stuck in my own head I was
worried so much about what other people
thought about me that I couldn't push
past it to just get my message out and
one of the things here at think media
that we love to help you with is your
mindset it takes work to get through the
things that have held you back I
personally know that confidence is
something that so many creators struggle
with I know that getting over what other
people think of you is something that we
struggle with and I know that actually
caring about the people you want to
impact that that can seem scary and so
we are here to help you with those
mindsets as you work through the
psychology that happens when creating
content this is hard work and I'm not
gonna say it isn't but I know that when
you can push through those things when
you have a mindset that's ready to rock
you can rock and the last part that I
think is the most special part about
growers video live is the community you
know when you think about show me your
friends and I'll show you your future
that has been something that has
impacted me more than anything in my
life I've made sure to put myself around
good mentors I've made sure to not be
the smartest person in to the room and
have people that are around me that I
can learn from you know I think there's
something so powerful when you think
about the people that you are around
that are speaking into your life what
does that do for you when it's positive
what does it do for you when you have
people who are dreamers just like you
what does it do for you when you know
that the people that are in your circle
are rooting for you I think it's so
important to know that in this business
you know online business it's isolating
it really can feel alone when you're
doing like I'm doing talking to a webcam
into a microphone by myself it's not
like a traditional business and so here
at think media and especially at our
conference
with video live you're gonna get
connected to community you're gonna get
connected to like-minded entrepreneurs
just like you you're gonna get connected
to people who can see what this can do
for them I think it's so powerful to
make sure that you are here at girl with
video live this year for not just the
strategy not just the psychology but for
the community there are hundreds of
thousands of creators out there just
like you and it grows video live you're
going to get to experience what it's
like to be in the room this is me doing
air quotes right now this is you being
in the room with them virtually from
your living room while experiencing this
conference so right now you can go to
growth video live and get your tickets
for as low as ninety seven dollars to
experience what we have for you in
September it's a three-day conference we
have our expert friends coming in
virtually so that you can experience
this from your living room block the
days on your calendars get ready I
cannot wait to see you as well as
thousands of other creators this year in
September I grow with video live well
thank you so much for watching this
episode or listening if you're on
podcasts and we're gonna move into the
iTunes review of the day you can go to
iTunes subscribe and make sure you rate
and review this podcast and maybe you
will be featured on a future podcast and
today's review comes from D Kurt Sean
and Heather together bring insane value
on this podcast they're bringing value
and actionable tips to the table on
every episode love the podcast I have
been listening since the start thank you
so much for leaving that review it means
so much to me to be able to go through
and read how your lives are being
changed by this podcast thank you for
being in community with us and being a
part of this from the beginning well
thank you so much for being here and I
can't wait to catch you in a future
hi